la décision est tombée pour ce chauffeur
de la ratp ahmed béral écope de deux
mois de mise à pied pour sa
participation aux mobilisations contre
la réforme des retraites
on lui reproche d'avoir contribué au
blocage de dépôts de bus l'hiver dernier
à pantin alors qu'ils étaient menacés de
licenciement c'était lui cgt présent
dans l'entreprise depuis 2004 a tout de
même évité le pire
voilà enfin contrat sera de deux mois de
mise à pied il gère à tout licenciement
et sera de deux mois de mise à pied bon
c'est cette cession s'inscrit en mai
c'est grâce au monde du rassemblement et
aux gens qui se mobilisent que la
direction a fait tueur marche arrière
parce que c'est pas un cadeau mais
autrefois sturm mieux que la porte après
maintenir aux prud'hommes pour leur
démontrer que même leurs deux mois
qu'ils se gardent pour le soutenir des
centaines de personnes étaient réunies
ce mercredi devant les locaux de la ratp
où se tenait le conseil de discipline
des collègues venus l'encourager avant
la décision de la direction mais aussi
d'autres membres de la cgt et des élus
politiques de gauche
c'est comme ça que fonctionne la ratp
ils pensent qu'en mettant deux mois
ahmed
mais bon ils vont ils vont emmerder
financièrement mais ils n'ont pas le
courage de le virer parce que ça veut
tout tout le casting pas le courage
qu'ils je suis pas autant dire qu'ils
auraient dû le faire c'est passé revers
mais voilà ils veulent faire mal
pécuniairement
aux militants syndicaux parce qu'ils
savent que s'ils vont trop loin de toute
façon ils vont leur prendre comme un
retour de bâton
mais c'est quand même inacceptable ahmed
il n'a pas à prendre deux mois
franchement c'est d'un ridicule mètres
de moi pour un secteur de la cct qui est
là pour la sécurité des agents et la
santé je trouve que c'est un scandale
au moins pour une fois la ratp a montré
son vrai visage cette sanctionner les
camarades et vraiment c'est inadmissible
on voit bien qu'il ya une volonté de la
part de la direction de la ratp de
criminaliser l'action syndicale de
sanctionner les meneurs de sanctionner
les fortes têtes ceux qui se lèvent et
qui disent non parce que il ya une
volonté de la part du gouvernement de
faire taire dans quelques semaines un
autre élu cgt
alexandre el gammal sera lui aussi
convoqué devant le même conseil
on lui reproche les mêmes faits de
blocage de son côté ahmed béral
n'éprouve aucun regret se dit prêt à
participer à de nouvelles mobilisations